вы никогда не научитесь управлять своим
стрессом и чувствовать себя
по-настоящему живым если не досмотрите
это видео до конца всё что вы знали о
балансе и спокойствии может оказаться
вашей главной ошибкой Если вы продолжите
следовать этому заблуждению вы рискуете
потерять контроль над своим здоровьем и
своей жизнью в конце видео я расскажу
вам о практическом подходе который
перевернёт ваше представление о том как
работать с нервной системой стрессом и
адаптивностью оставайтесь до конца это
изменит ваш взгляд на то как вы живёте
большинство из нас живёт в плену ложного
убеждения что для счастья и успеха нужно
стремиться к балансу Если вы слышали про
такое убеждение то Поставьте лайк этому
видео Мы хотим уравновесить работу и
личную жизнь искать покоя избегать
стресса более того мы следуем так
называемому колесу баланса в жизни это
звучит очень разумно и правда ли Но вот
в чём дело всё это на самом деле миф
научные исследования показывают что наша
нервная система более здорова и
устойчива когда она способна
переключаться между состояниями
активности и расслабления Ани когда
находится в постоянном состоянии покоя
или баланса в кавычках научные
исследования доказывают что для
эффективной работы нервной системы
необходима гибкость а не стабильность
стабильность убивает нашу нервную
систему если ваша нервная система
застревает в одном состоянии например в
постоянном стрессе это разрушает ваш
организм А если вы слишком долго
пытаетесь оставаться в спокойствии вы
теряете способность адекватно
реагировать на вызовы жизни Посмотрите
на современных детей ведь большинство из
них не способны переносить стрессы и
нагрузки то что мы в детстве считали
нормой для современных детей является
стрессом посмотрите сколько сейчас
появилось психологов и коучей вы ВС ещ
думаете что важно поддерживать баланс
гибкость нашей нервной сие это ключ к
здоровью наша нервная система как и всё
живое оно требует гибкости это
способность легко переключаться между
состояниями напряжения и расслабления
оно называется ещё нейропластичность или
автономной гибкостью Представьте себе
что ваш ум и тело умеют мгновенно
реагировать на стресс а затем с такой же
лёгкостью расслабляться и
восстанавливаться это то что делает нас
по-настоящему
устойчивыми почему это важно
Потому что жизнь - это постоянное
изменение исследования показывают что
стресс будучи временным может оказывать
положительное влияние на здоровье и
развитие но только при условии что после
стрессовой ситуации ваш организм
способен быстро переключиться в
состояние расслабления это называется
концепцией
аллозавр зма достигать стабильности
через изменения Но что если я скажу вам
что наш стресс - это не враг что если я
скажу вам что без стресса вы никогда не
станете сильнее умнее и успешнее если вы
не научитесь правильно переключаться
между состояниями это может разрушить
вашу карьеру ваши отношения и Ваше
здоровье в конце
концов оставайтесь со мной потому что в
этом видео я расскажу вам как развить
эту самую важную для вашей жизни
способность Почему избегание стресса
разрушает вас многие из Нас боятся
стресса боятся как огня
мы избегаем любых напряжённых ситуаций и
стремимся к спокойствию Но вы должны
понять одну очень важную вещь стресс -
это не враг исследования подтверждают
что умеренный уровень стресса
стимулирует развитие когнитивных
способностей и адаптацию наоборот он
может стать вашим союзником Если вы
научитесь правильно с ним работать И
кстати если вам интересны подобные темы
обязательно подпишитесь на мой Telegram
канал где Я делюсь лайфхаками и мыслями
о бизнесе инвестициях жизни и
самосовершенствовании ссылку вы найдёте
в описании к этому видео вообще что
такое стресс Давайте поймём стресс - это
ваша физиологическая и психологическая
реакция организма на внешние или
внутренние раздражителей которые требуют
мобилизации ресурсов и адаптации к новым
условиям стресс - это старший брат
страха только более
долгосрочный если страх - это
краткосрочная физиологическая и
психологическая реакция организма на
конкретную реальную или мнимую опасность
то стресс - это продолжительный страх
возникающий перед долгосрочной и
продолжительной опасностью при страхе
или при стрессе происходит выброс
одинаковых гормонов адреналина и
кортизола в этом они абсолютно идентичны
вопрос только в интенсивности и
продолжительности выброса этих гормонов
Если вы постоянно находитесь в состоянии
стресса и не даёте себе возможности
расслабиться ваша нер система теряет
гибкость и это приводит к состояниям
хронической усталости депрессии апатии и
других психосоматических заболеваний Вот
почему важно развивать способность
переключаться между напряжением и
расслаблением Обратите внимание как всё
устроено в природе антилопа только что
была в стрессе и убегала от
гепарда как только она убежала она уже
мирно пас на лужайке дикие животные
показывают нам примеры адаптивности этот
навык может спасти вашу карьеру ваше
здоровье и вашу жизнь и в этом видео я
научу вас как это делать Представьте
себя в конце напряжённого дня ваша
голова раскалывается от стресса А тело
хочет лишь одного отдыха но вместо того
чтобы полноценно расслабиться вы
продолжаете думать о проблемах вы не
можете отпустить ситуацию и начинаете
выгорать если обратиться к теме
депрессивных состояний
посттравматических
расстройств то часто в особенно в
научной литературе об этом говорят так
как о потере пластичности
нейропластичность это знакомо Вот теперь
Представьте что у вас есть навык который
позволяет вам легко переключаться на
отдых Представьте что после ревой
ситуации вы можете мгновенно
расслабиться как будто нажимайте на
кнопку перезагрузка ваша нервная система
восстанавливается и Вы снова чувствуете
энергию и ясность Вот что значит
нейропластичность
исследования показывают что регулярная
тренировка нервной системы через
осознанные дыхательные практики либо
физические упражнения либо испытывали
краткосрочных острых стрессов укрепляет
её способность адаптироваться и это
кстати одна из причин почему я постоянно
тренируюсь преодолевать свои страхи
прыгая то с самой высокой тарзанки в
мире то прыгая с парашютом то спускаясь
на самом длинном зиплайне который давно
я в октябре в Дубае это делал то летая
на плане на Рио до Жанейро то купаясь в
самых холодных речках и озёрах Ну и так
далее я на самом деле таким образом
тренирую свою автономную гибкость или
свой алаз Напишите как вы преодолевали
или преодолевай свои страхи Напишите про
свои инструменты и техники очень
интересно будет прочитать про эти методы
инструменты не только мне учитесь
восстанавливаться после любого стресса
Давайте себе время востановления даже
короткие моменты тишины и медитации тут
помогут вам восстановить вашу нервную
систему второе не избегайте стресса
Используйте его не бойтесь сложностей
стресс - это тренировка для вашей
нервной системы Если вы научитесь
правильно переключаться то стресс станет
вашим помощником третье Создайте баланс
между напряжением и отдыхом вводите в
свою жизнь стрессовые стимулы например
холодный душ или интенсивные тренировки
но обязательно Не забывайте о
восстановлении Это простые шаги они
могут изменить вашу жизнь если вам
интересны подобные практики кстати
подписывайтесь на мой Telegram канал где
Я делюсь лайфхаками о том как
использовать эти принципы в бизнесе
инвестициях и личной эффективности
ссылку Ищите в описании к этому видео
Итак алас - это Ключевая концепция
динамического
равновесия Давайте поговорим о важной
концепции которая изменит ваше понимание
того как работает здоровье и успех это
называется
лоста напротив гомеостаза в отличие от
гомеостаза состояние постоянного
равновесия которое подразумевает
стабильность лоста означает постоянное
приспособление к изменениям Представьте
себе что ваше тело ваш бизнес и даже
ваша нервная система достигают
стабильности не через покой А через
способность быстро адаптироваться К
любым переменам кстати Если вы хотите
визуально представить что такое алос то
вот смотрите когда вы сидите на
трёхколёсном велосипеде и никуда не
едете Ну то есть у вас гомеостаз то есть
устойчивая трёхколёсная система
стремится к тому чтобы оставаться в
покое стабильность А если вы сидите на
двух колёсном велосипеде то Вам не
удастся стоять на месте так вот чтобы
удерживать тоже самое равновесие вам
нужно двигаться впер и это как раз
показывает как работает алос Это
достижение динамического равновесия за
счёт постоянного приспособления так вот
алаз - это динамическое равновесие и это
то что делает вас по-настоящему
устойчивыми все живые системы будь то
человеческий организм экосистема или
социальная структура достигают
стабильности не через фиксированный
баланс А через постоянное приспособление
к изменению вот Это главно по
основные принципы лоста Давайте разберём
первое отход от статического понимания
баланса вместо стремление к
фиксированному состоянию мы говорим о
динамической адаптации второе
переключение как ключевой навык
способность быстро переходить между
различными состояниями например
напряжением и расслаблением важнее чем
поддержание одного состояния третье
стабильность через изменения система
становится более устойчивой благодаря
своей способности меняться а не
сопротивляться
изменениям
четвёртое адаптивность Как здоровье Вы
должны здоровье рассматривать с точки
зрения адаптивности здоровье
определяется способностью эффективно
реагировать на вызовы и возвращаться в
своё функциональное состояние пятое
тренировка пластичности акцент на
развитии навыка переключения между
состояниями а не на постоянном
спокойствии или тамм открыто
пер перейм к
практике Вы научитесь переключаться
между состояниями напряжения и
расслабления как будто нажимаете на
тумблер или на кнопку впустите в свою
жизнь больше хаоса Не бойтесь
раскрываться и не бойтесь беспорядка в
своей жизни ведь там где царствует
абсолютный порядок Там нет жизни Вот
несколько простых упражнений которым
можно внедрить свою жизнь смотрите после
интенсивного стресса сделайте глубокий
вдох
на 4 секунды и медленно Выдыхай
Повторите несколько раз и вы
почувствуете Как ваша нервная система
успокаивается добавьте в свою жизнь
регулярные стрессовые стимулы например
интервальные тренировки или закаливание
холодом Это поможет вашему организму
лучше
адаптироваться учитесь отпускать
контроль Вот это большая Боль у многих
бизнесменов иногда расслабление - это
просто умение довериться себе и своим
ресурсам и вот что важно не
демонизировать
заключается в способности гибко
адаптироваться и переключаться между
состояниями А это требует тренировки Но
помимо тренировок Я
рекомендую использовать этот алаз или
динамическое равновесие как образ жизни
тогда вам меньше нужно будет
тренироваться если это у вас будет образ
жизни такой вот я стараюсь весь свой
образ жизни подгонять под это у меня
постоянные переезды постоянные какие-то
стрессы постоянные какие-то то период
покоя то восстановление то я очень много
общаюсь то я э провожу много времени в
одиночестве размышляя то я максимально
открыт то я максимально закрыт и это у
меня образ жизни так вот вы можете с
одной стороны тренироваться а с другой
стороны Я
рекомендую заниматься даже не
тренировками а весь свой образ жизни
привести в такое динамическое равновесие
если это видео изменило ваш взгляд на
привычные вещи обязательно подпишитесь
на канал Ставьте лайк и делитесь своими
мыслями в комментариях